[Applause]
[Music]
how are you senator I am doing terrific
[Music]
steven crowder is a self-styled commedia
that bill cosby says that being declared
a sexually violent predator is going to
damage his reputation not available for
comment we're all the women that he
raped those guys a dick I disagree would
you like to change my mind yeah
hello this is Canada time to listen up
you silly liberal fruitcakes
[Music]
[Applause]
that's not going to happen
alright U of M Nutella Crowder's coming
to help coming with me here
[Music]
welcome all you gangsters and free
speech dogs show them hands let me see
them mugs
hey now welcome to Detroit City I said
welcome to Detroit City every place
everywhere we go yeah a [ __ ] trying to
ban our show but it's going down a
Detroit City louder with Crowder and
Detroit City ooh
Ann Arbor's uh it's not really the same
Mike what y'all mean like well they
don't really like to be a so I should be
associated with Detroit not at all yeah
okay but in the light like a suburb yo
no no they're not really that way I mean
they have like their own zip code
7:34 I believe yeah yeah I mean it's
really kind of its own it's kind of its
own thing I guess I had the wrong zip
code but we come another drew our show I
said welcome to Ann Arbor city it's not
Detroit in our city it's Detroit two
syllables Ann Arbor is I see read yeah
it's too tall too it's the only two did
I see the problem struck a do oh yeah
although cause they caught em - yeah I
mean that's right I mean it's like Ann
Arbor that's - yeah so it's a - hey now
welcome to a - City I said welcome to a
-
every place everywhere we go yeah they
whine try to ban our show but we're here
now an a to city louder with Crowder and
a to City trick poets as soon as I hit
the road
you can him it hollom our club in this
[ __ ] let me hear you come on club in
this [ __ ]
let me hear you harm our club in this
[ __ ] so we're gonna call when you wanna
have a laugh put me in the club come on
let me see them hands in this guy free
speech in and over till we die all you
gangsters of free speech Stubbs broke
them hands and we show them mugs hey now
welcome to
sitting I said welcome to a2 city every
place everywhere we go yeah they wanna
try to ban our show but we're here now
an a2 city
louder with Crowder and Angel City I'm
the trucker super juicer I'm a
quarterback I think it's time to hero
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah oh you got it
daddy's gonna be a very uneven Mogga
helmet
oh you know Oh University of Michigan
glad to be here all right let's now
let's let him hear you in the overflow
room they couldn't get tickets but
they're in there yeah they're like we
don't love them that much yeah you know
for people watching on YouTube you guys
can grab a seat but do you understand
this whole time
I'm not gonna be passing around a cup
everybody passes out after this you can
sit it makes me very uncomfortable if
you say standing like that it gives the
protesters every reason to show up okay
we were streaming live question
obviously do you guys whatever out there
on YouTube obviously a lot of talk about
bombs lately no one here supports that
I'm pretty sure
unfortunately the blame game is being
played you've seen this from Donald
Trump's rhetoric to the media what do
you think you think the blameless at
rest squarely in the shoulder is a guy
who who sent the bum or people or Z's I
don't know also if you're on YouTube a
very popular answer is quote the Jews so
that's always yeah you can't get around
it you cannot get around it on the
YouTube let me see your phones show your
phones we have some press here tonight
in Ann Arbor some pictures Instagram
that whatever you want to do Crowder U
of M takeover is a hashtag let the press
know that you were every bit as much
story and I leave a promo code U of M we
get a $30 a month club if you join up
bloggers better not come /mo clever
deals who don't know if any mug clubbers
in the house and we'll be talking a
little bit later a dive in second I
think they call it now we always called
it a meet segment about college
conservatism the statistics might
surprise you but leading the news we
have to talk about this first president
Trump held a rally in Wisconsin where he
addressed the the recent bomb scares you
guys might have seen this he called for
unity which I thought was was pretty
nice many of course are immediately
accusing him of very quickly pivoting to
attacking his political opponents rather
than actually unifying and giving a
speech I you know we have an exclusive
you be the judge we would
all sides to come together in peace and
harmony we could do it even like Ted
crazy birdie
hottest she could do it and even that
live filthy [ __ ] Hillary Clinton
No yeah no he doesn't have the hang of
it yet don't encourage his behavior wait
hold on I'm actually receiving word that
we have right now we didn't know we have
briefing footage of the caravan of
course you know with migrant children
and women seeking a better life in the
United States we go now live some
coverage yeah even once again criminals
is everywhere okay
it's criminal thing here well I mean it
is the opposite I would say so I would
say so it's almost like I lied to you I
make no apologies turning to
international news my home country of
Canada where I was raised
down shame we're conservatives we
believe in shame so turn in the
International News Canada has already
nearly run out of marijuana
immediately after legalizing there you
go and
No
[Applause]
the line of the day gentlemen Gerald
Morgan Jr junior white glove service
[Music]
enough ease him little cabernet
sauvignon you said Wow rules change when
you're on a college campus I guess yeah
no this is a grape-juice we had to make
sure that we are your campus police
you're doing a job and you never want to
speak ill of anyone in blue but you know
unlike those sons of [ __ ] at
University of Illinois already stepped
on one joke grab a seat okay this is
what I do for the show let's try this
again
- cute Nattie and overlays by the way
she just she's too cute it makes me want
to throw up no throwing up right now she
needs to eat a little bit she needs to
feel some shitty make some bad decisions
then we can have her on our team yeah I
threw up in my mouth she's just too cute
look at that it's like a mean Cobra Kai
damn it - cute Matty okay turning to
international news Canada nearly run out
of marijuana
immediately after legalizing it thank
you - cute Matty direct quotes problems
started on the first day said Patrick
Wallace it's a mess Wow the supply is
just a mess he's the owner of a 420
store and many of you may not know this
Gerald knows this because he played
football at Notre Dame and you know
spend a lot of time here in away games
come on
that's worse pandering than Hillary
Clinton's come on now I know what a
button does it now I know why she does
it
she's like a bald eagle in an oil spill
just many of you may not know but he
knows because he played it I love also
by the way that Notre Dame didn't get as
big of a boo as the one person from
Canada it still is kind of alright so
many of you may not know this you do
because you put a lot of away games here
in Ann Arbor actually Canada followed
the municipality of Ann Arbor's lead on
marijuana laws which let's be honest
given the Canadian Prime Minister really
shouldn't surprise anybody here Yama's
your City Commissioner yes I'm happy to
say that Kyra definitely did
following our Bursley really let me ask
you do you find that when people are
completely ripped and your bones they
don't even notice the Muslim right
[Music]
all right he's a horrible world
leadership added earlier I do appreciate
though the laugh at the Dearborn Islamic
rape joke so that'll go far tells me the
kind of crowd you are yeah oh we should
probably get rid of that camera in his
office by the way that's very helpful
listen I do wanna I seriously talking
about what's your opinion here on the
the bombs that have gone out recently is
is obviously we don't have a lot of info
yet no no no how many of you watch the
show but we typically don't comment on
situations where there isn't a ton of
info because you always almost always
end up being embarrassed oh yeah you
gotta wait you got wait and so Gerald
you go ahead you definitely have to wait
to get some more information but I look
if it's somebody from our political
standpoint they think that's the way
that we're going to advance our agenda
that's not going to work our ideas can
stand for themselves the Democrats and
the Liberals cannot exist they talk
about the all right and crazy concerns
let it by round of applause who here is
against bombs no matter who it is
whether it's the Clintons the Obamas
we don't want anyone on the other side
getting hurt except Robert De Niro maybe
a little bit a little bit a mousetrap
like snip Oh was that a mousetrap for me
yeah that was for you you haven't done
good work since Cape Fear you switching
to entertainment kind of Caitlyn Jenner
said that he/she Z I'm just trying to
make sure that I get everybody offended
right off the bat you'd want to get it
to play a Marvel villain this comes from
comicbook.com direct quote yeah no no
seriously seriously
save it for Canada or DC okay let's yeah
Aquaman talks to fish comicbook.com I
want to play the baddest fast lady
you've ever seen in your life I got the
wicked queen or the wicked lady
mr. Luthor makeup from the outfit and
I've got the deep voice well you've got
part of that so quick to oblige of
course and jump on the lgbtq bandwagon
Marvel actually announced their newest
super villain in the Marvel Universe to
be Caitlyn Jenner yeah that makes sense
that seems yeah yeah I can see it
let's see it I can see it I mean I'd
watch it yeah I wouldn't I would hope
you'd have to go to yours to see that
motion picture now Kaitlynn story arc
actually this is true story remains a
little bit of a mystery but because of
comic-con leaks I don't only big comic
book fans yeah there's in the comic-con
leagues suggest Caitlyn's involvement in
the newly announced plotline Santos the
intergalactic transphobes seems there's
a bucket out back by the way Caitlyn
Jenner has the power of supersonic speed
telekinesis and the ability to not go to
jail when she runs you over with her car
so that's a good one across with Kevin
Spacey and the Joker from the animated
series we're actually honored tonight to
be joined by a Supreme Court justice in
the audience
we don't have necessarily agree with
this person but none other than Ruth
Bader Ginsburg justice do we have the
ruby game available yeah let's okay Shh
all right she's sleeping quiet
okay everyone be quiet please this is
thank God you didn't pay for this show
all right finally in the final news
story before we get to some more news
that we have to get to a PETA has
officially claimed cow's milk to be a
symbol of white supremacy so I want to
make sure I get this right the group
renewed its claim from a 20-17 blog post
titled cow's milk is the perfect to
drink for white supremacist tweeted a
link out recently this last week to
renew it I guess that's how it works the
National Dairy Association responded to
the claims calling them absurd and
insulting naturally now though to be
fair here's the I'm a milk guy yeah I
like no I'm not on board with PETA but I
can see how they could argue that the
recent got milk campaigns were
distasteful I can understand them yeah
that's makes sense I get it that's
dippity at a gray territory it would
seem what was the writing you don't see
if that was German was it great hi big
Mitch I don't even know I don't know
that's how the mustache started I can't
read it I can't read it
we're getting word of developments with
the carrier and migrant women and
children as you know the United States
we return to coverage live
he's criminal Singh here well I mean it
I think this yeah he doesn't seem like
he's much help Hey 1kings accurate that
I did want to tell you guys I'm really
sorry you saw on the posters my good
friend Owen Benjamin was supposed to be
here tonight but he couldn't make it
because a family affair too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this town ain't big enough for the two
of us
actually in a matter of fact
geographically there is physical room
for I've had enough of yours bestest
Leighton smug talk
fill your tumbler you suck
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well now Owen I just wanted to thank you
for that wonderful performance you put
on for these folks yes well I think that
showed Owen from your passionate
performance all the way to your perfect
Liberace costume now Owen have you been
following this unfortunate story of the
administration wanting to reclassify
one's gender to identify with their
biological sex no see gender exists
outside the realm of science well Owen
gender actually exists outside that
simple binary you referred to as boy and
girl that also exists outside of that
feedback you see actually gender can be
expressed in a multitude of ways you can
be LGBTQ there's 57 others depending on
the day and you can switch right back
including your sexuality thanks to the
modern phenomenon known as gender
fluidity
[Music]
[Laughter]
well Owen in a way in a way I suppose it
is like magic but let me tell you it's
not always easy for [ __ ] out there
on the range no oh and I'm talking about
difficulties that far exceed the
silliness of cutting off one's pick or
replacing it with a non-functioning
vagina that you're about able for
evermore try to close as a wound I'm
talking about problems for [ __ ] out
on the range that live more in the realm
of nuance
matter of fact let me tell you a story
about a little [ __ ] I knew let me tell
you a story about this [ __ ] named sue
[Applause]
when I was born the doctor said it's a
boy but pissing off doctors gave mama
joy so she put me in a dress in
high-heeled shoes
he gopal thought it wrong cuz I still
had a dong and he said little boys
shouldn't wear little girl thongs all
laugh wasn't easy for little [ __ ]
named sue about junior high I stopped
being a guy and of kids and asked why
I'd let out a big sigh and I just have
the school give them the boot yeah you
did well College got better so I still
had my pecker I sure was one Hill
trendsetter free to drop a deuce in the
men's or ladies room okay he picked that
deuce anywhere he wants you for a Susan
Bellone even though I still had a bone
but what do you know it turns out I was
a true
[Music]
I didn't hear that because I was hearing
feet my hat was falling on my own
eyeballs I tell you what cowboy Liberace
that's a weird combo let's play me back
in they threw an even more scholarship
money and they just asked me please
don't sue us honey all life wasn't easy
for a little [ __ ] named sue did you
sue sue your name is sue I feel like
that's kind of hilarious if you sued
them and I listened okay that's let's
just let's curb that sorry I got real
accessory to zeal but it's making of my
hats about to fall off all right let's
just slow down let's put me back in
well a man told me late one night after
15 Bud Lights disregarding my hide me
you sure are good-looking sue you
now I said just between us I might have
a penis though it's more of a weenus and
he was out of gas but my big ol size 15
shoe damn that's a big shoe shoe
well wouldn't you know as I began to
disrobe and I started the probe turns
out Transpo
ah hell what's a poor [ __ ] to do he
screams you're a man driving back his
Dodge Ram all just because I didn't have
a clam oh-ho laughs wasn't easy for a
little training name soon years went by
and my own little guy and I knew what I
have to choose how he'd identify and oh
boy I didn't know what to do the hormone
blockers weren't the answer as it turned
out I gave the little bastard cancer
watch won't be easy for a
second-generation
named Sue
[Applause]
biology's a [ __ ] Owen Benjamin ladies
and gentlemen huge pianists by the way
Johnny boy my producer he's rushing to
try and get us back on track let's hear
it for ya
and he still screwed it up oh man I hope
you're having a good time everyone out
there why am I still doing this
yeah cut cut that out hey super wine oh
and I want Owen back right now I got to
find out where I am so how many of you
would declare themselves conservative
libertarian right-wing
yeah all right was hoping for a little
more diversity you know what we actually
still have we do in our myths we do want
to check back in on Supreme Court
justice do we have the roof cam Ruth
Bader Ginsberg ladies and gentlemen and
she D is she here all right you know
what let's sit back on that let's just
yeah that might be in the QA oh goodness
um you know we hear this talked about a
whole lot you've heard this term
probably for many of your professors who
are out there protesting other
right who here's heard the term about
other okay apparently no one they say we
will not make a noise unless it's booing
a Canadian okay everything else and we
hear a lot about this right we hear a
lot about black people gay people trans
people about being other de bout being
marginalized and here's the truth
statistic once one person's cheering
with a club looks like a mid 90s rave
and he's taking a cocktail of codeine
and E with seven fingers you Andrew
don't make a cute couple service but
statistically the one thing that a lot
of people don't talk about is no one has
been other
no one has been other don college
campuses more than conservatives now
before we get to the statistics let's
show some stories that you probably know
let's show the anecdotal here's a real
also a group of conservative students
kicked off their campus coffee shop for
wearing make America great hats again
during this love well then
white supremacist and a vice president
that is one of the most anti-gay at this
point it's not even education anymore
it's indoctrination and we began with a
legal battle that is brewing a student
group claims it was ousted by Lone Star
College over its conservative view now
it's taking college leadership to court
the piece at the University of Alaska
Anchorage depicting Captain America
holding the president's severed head he
was told he had to apologize in front of
class then silently while they critiqued
him she didn't like the fact that I
disagreed with the subject being pushed
in class being by the way please give it
up for ya from college Republicans who
put this on for you against the
administration let him hear ya and the
overflow room thank you guys and
everyone has already been given tickets
to the after party we appreciate it so
much you guys have been so accommodating
and I don't know if you know this but
actually this very show before when it
actually started out of a station here
named whammy in Ann Arbor that was the
first show I ever actually had to call
my own good a couple of people good
we're up at 6 a.m. yeah you know and you
were probably 12 years old a lot of
Trudeau's out there so does anyone know
the actual number as far a lot because
people talk about this a lot right
people if you don't want to be folks who
just [ __ ] and you're not armed with
information does anyone know the actual
number of professors on college campus
they net they out well let's do that's
good that's a good guess but I think you
just picked the lowest of the numbers
there's zero zeros matter number one
what 1% I'll get a t-shirt no the ratio
of leftist to conservative professors
across this country you have an idea
well now you kind of me so you stole my
thunder
okay alright it's not it's 12 to 1
alright so sorry look 20 to 1 a million
to one
it's 12 to 1 which I thought was pretty
bad and here's something that's crazy to
me 39 percent of colleges across the
country have 0 no conservative
professors at all whether there's an
overlay there are two cute Maddy Hill
she's so cute makes me disgusted boo so
basically 40% of universities and
college campuses have no even leaning
right professors at what point do we
acknowledge that it's not just
happenstance missus can you find 40
percent of college professors can you
find 40 percent of colleges that have no
zero not one atheist professor Nina Oh
Buddhist professors no environmentalist
professors can you find me forty percent
of colleges that don't have a single
professor who likes Jolly Ranchers if
you're playing the odds game there isn't
this statistically doesn't matter how
many times you roll the dice zero that's
almost half and by the way a majority of
college students how many people agree
with this when polled a majority of
college students and by the way the poll
really matters here because you're
asking people's opinion it's not like a
poll on health care from Bernie Sanders
are you happy with your health care you
son of a [ __ ] yeah I think it's all
right
[Laughter]
no not as bad as was Alexandria Nina
Pinta sent ya one of those belly Larry
Curly moe Cortez I can't get the names
right look is this because it's Latino
you know but let's go with that I don't
I don't turn the argument you just call
me a racist and I'll be on my way let's
do that
what are you a racist sure sure yeah
okay all right there's a fire sauce I
don't want to have a conversation with a
drive-through here a majority of college
students that they feel there's a
climate on campus that's completely
hostile toward them anyone else
show of hands around of applause I can't
see you feel that way on campus there's
a few and here's the thing it would be
what yeah you're not alone right a big
part of why we do this show a big part
of why sometimes we go a little bit too
far with the jokes and I know some of
you tomorrow will be telling your you'll
be like Peter before the rooster crows
three times I didn't go to a lotta with
druthers row and your local paper is
gonna be like okay he has a christ
complex but we do it so you don't have
to be afraid it's okay to be who you are
we hear that all the time you're perfect
just the way you are first off none of
you are perfect most of you suck all of
a sock okay
I suck you suck gerald certainly sucks
but what but that's okay but then we're
told you're fine just accept yourself
where you are
well what if you're conservative what if
you're a right-leaning person on campus
where you're outnumbered twelve to
twelve to one not by students but by
your professors we're 40% of you are on
a college campus with not one person who
shares your worldview that's how would
the Turk well I let's not go with burn
it down all right
that's the guy sending clock boy
envelopes I check him out got a good
plan not a good plan how funny would
that people were just clock boy I suck
as a person and David hogs like I heard
suck as a person all right listen
he's 18 it's fine he's 18 it's fine yeah
you can do it now it's on it's on time
did you see David hog try to encourage
Canadians to commit election fraud
that's like now even Michael Moore was
like performing and usually it's one
thing for professors to be all far left
and all of your students to be far left
it's one thing for you to be afraid
simply simply to speak out and that is
the norm right a lot of people accept
that that is the new norm but it gets
even worse when you look at today and
we're not supposed to use the M word M
as an marsupial o people out there okay
you're not suppose to use the M we're
talking about mobs but the truth is on
campus and we've experienced this as
well as in the country at large to left
today these people who make up 40% of
college campuses but there's not a
single one of you teaching these people
who outnumber other professors twelve to
one are getting increasingly violent and
rioting and you see it escalating here
don't think my word for
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
others wore masks through what appeared
to be fireworks and smoke bombs then
started fires there have been no
immediate reports of arrests hmm none
none that strike you as weird and I know
we're not supposed to use the n-word
today but I say it because listen guys I
know it's kind of hard to say something
serious here with my package hanging out
do as I do
not as I say you know just do none of it
but honestly and before we get to the
Q&A here we're gonna line up I save this
so that all of you out there you see
these mobs you see people pulling folks
from cars and Portland old man trying to
beat them up I love you saw this video
just made my blood absolutely boil you
don't have to be afraid you don't have
to be afraid to speak up it's why my
answers have changed in the Q&A when I
used to say listen keep your head down
and stay safe it's why my worldview has
changed because they will smell it on
you you cannot hide it and that's why
we're out here this is really hard give
it up for the team of people who've made
this happen to by the way
[Applause]
we get a mic with a longer cord off
that's possible entire staff made this
happen because we want to come out and
just let you guys know that there are
other people out there like you they may
not be your teachers they may not be
your friends in college they may not be
the people writing the papers about
today's about today's event but you know
what they are out there and before we
move on to QA I think we do actually
have to go one more time to our if we
have our Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg or
the roof cam
yeah the roof camera are we oh oh oh no
[Music]
she's a fighting one to pull this all
right there we go all right that's it
for this material here we're gonna go to
QA for you guys thank you so much to go
to the overflow room you guys you're
fantastic we're gonna keep this go we're
gonna come visit you after we do this QA
yeah let's look we have microphones here
on the right and on the left University
of Michigan anyone who wants to ask a
question feel free to come on up you can
ignore the people who are gonna write
about you tomorrow in college paper
because they're not gonna be friendly
anyway and by the way where's the guy
who's dressed up as a mug where is it
yes let me hear you change alright yeah
pretty good one is that a kiddie pool
that you just put tape on there it is
yeah want to see what he for sure that's
epic that is so good oh yes to put it on
before he goes to QA alright and he
can't make it let me walk sideways I'm
kind of a ruckus solving this thing
shouldn't it shoot so much gum [ __ ]
alright don't knock it over just go
around and come back okay alright maybe
this wasn't the best idea what's your
name sir my name is James James thank
you for being here James thank you for
the effort
now James tell me what is this that you
put together how did you make this I
took a couple of cheap yoga mats a pool
noodle and a hula-hoop okay beautiful
yeah and it caused you a girlfriend I'm
guessing it might have yeah why do you
have to dress this way why can't you
just be normal no I'm telling afterwards
we can get into the mug we can do some
weird stuff make some bad decisions
disgusting you want to be my mug if not
you're not a part of my so how long did
this take you
I started Sunday morning and I finished
last night wow wow you're definitely
feeling at least a class yeah give it to
him this is his moment better make it
count thank you so much sure I
appreciate your mug club member you're
the winner of the costume contest any
merch you want couple of shirts Ranger
but you want some Ranger panties you
want to wear some Ranger patties all
right
all the above thank you sir let's hear
it for them costume contest winner all
right I guess you know what we'll start
right here you know okay we'll go over
here with the next first question oh
jeez what happened there I was like
Satan's piss all right you sir in the
cage looking very angry what's your name
that's just my natural face but alright
go job interview I will be thrilled if
you choose me
sorry sure about that shut up I'm
finishing okay Evan so this is the cake
yeah I hope setup this is what we are
worse thank you so much Evan I don't get
any feedback go ahead with your question
at all so listen just as a conservative
on campus yeah today in one of my
classes
a Spanish seminar of all things we were
learning about why Christianity is more
violent than Islam yeah that's not well
listen that just brings up my question
is that as a conservative and might as a
Christian a devout Christian on campus
you know I am afraid to you know speak
up in a second language at that you know
just be like what's your first language
that's English but um I think if you
learn the general precept of second
language okay but okay all right well
I'm wasting time but anyway my question
is you know are you sure you want to be
a nightclub comic Evan go ahead sir it's
gonna be it's gonna fun let's you know
let's have fun it's just I find it hard
to disagree with the sentiment of just
sort of just eating the crap that your
professors give you getting the grade
and then once you're out of school
fighting to make a difference yeah
because I find that sentiment rather
enticing honestly because I understand
our grades are important as student
course and I'm just wondering do you
have any advice for students in my
position German want to be able to stop
the indoctrination on campus but don't
necessarily want our numbers to suffer
as a result
well thank you Evan for the ride a block
that you miss mile
[Applause]
now can we smile by the way I don't know
if they're any antiphon members here
they were threatening to throw a big old
bottle of piss at me tonight so target
right here where are they listen that's
a valid question and I understand it
okay and this is the question I get
asked most and we do the life advice
segment where a tough-love with your
guru dr. Crowder yeah I'm legally I
can't say I'm a doctor but I'm a doctor
I think first off I know this sounds
trivial it does help to smile to be
jovial to be a happy warrior that's not
just something that I'm you're Dennis
Prager talks about how it's your moral
obligation to be happy and as Christians
we talk about being happy being content
being at least grateful through
suffering right that's what I believe I
genuinely do I feel that it is such a
privilege to be able to come out here
and perform for you guys and ensure that
doors are closed for me the
entertainment industry and when you talk
about it's an enticing idea right oh and
they're definitely closed
he also can't walk through half of them
I get that it's an enticing idea and I
used to answer this question if people
go back and watch the older videos
rested you know what I understand it do
what you got to do keep your head down
the problem is you would have to believe
that all these professors the 12 to one
are idiots without Twitter Instagram
Facebook there is no way to stay hidden
in 2018 that's why I changed my answer
my opinion hasn't changed if there were
if you had the ability right to stay off
of social media completely to be
completely google proof to every single
professor you could guarantee that they
wouldn't know yeah listen sure go ahead
ace your classes and then get yourself
into some kind of position of authority
watch the YouTube people or know like
the Jews and then do more good but
you're not able to do that in 2018
that's why I think it's so important for
you to hear the people next to you
Yelling's but you know there are this
listen you guys aren't that small of a
minority you are definitely that small
of a minority as it's resent represented
in media as it's represented in the
faculty as it's represented in the press
but you are not that small of a minority
when it comes to people even when it
comes to the student body you know what
you are you're the students you're the
piece of the pie who elect presidents
for about that
and I'm sorry that my opinion changed a
little bit we have conservatives really
I just want to pass I want to go into
the stem field I want to be an engineer
and then if it's like you can't do it
it's not possible so what I want you to
do is grab the phone number or the hand
of the person next to you it's a tangle
you know all right here we are we're in
it now you're in if anyone you ever been
in the fight you don't stop after even
punched in the face you've all been
punched in the face now I'm not saying
go out and punch them in the face or
start mailing clocks okay what I am
saying is there's no way to hide it
you've been punched in the face you're
in the fight whether you want it or not
so start acting like it because there's
no way around it
and you help the person next to you and
I want to come back to that afterwards
because I'd like to close on that point
I really do see and I get a lot of
emails regarding fear on campus and it
surely does it breaks my heart I feel
totally humbled to be able to come out
here and perform for you guys because I
know how scary it is I know how other
you've been thank you thank you so much
you serve with a noise cancelling
headphones what's your name Logan Logan
nice to meet you Logan
so all right my second question can I
get a handshake no okay
because I don't know you and Jeff might
shoot you okay it's very fast I don't
want to get shot he's almost shot it
literally was reading about baggies of
piss being thrown at me before coming
onstage and you're like I've got a
goatee and spacers in my ears noodle
nothing personal I hope you understand
all right go ahead sir so I'm a senior
in high school and me and maybe my
friends we're conservatives we all have
the conservative views getting really
into politics in the last couple of
years yeah but my friends don't seem to
understand why they're conservative it's
more of like a they know the
conservative ways the better way to go
but they don't really know how to argue
their point okay so is there really such
thing as a bad conservative in that
sense that they can't help us push the
agenda they can just state it yes the
way this guy was looking at his watch
and then sort of tweeting something
right here what were you doing you were
like
you'd better hurry up I want to get to
the after-party
your wife's watching thankful thank you
very much for your what's your name sir
what's your wife's name
actually why couldn't she be here
tonight three kids well that's here for
Michael Ashley yeah three children
that's a powerful woman I sure hope the
kids aren't watching tonight I mean
what's a ranger panty it's what's barely
hiding what's in there son
yes listen they're gonna be back usually
doesn't mean they're bad people but can
there be bad conservatives we're not
able to represent the view point
properly yeah you see them all the time
what's part two yeah oh thank you man I
appreciate thanks for the question yes
it's simple answer and I know a lot of
the time we like to act as though there
is not a simple answer sometimes there
is a simple answer and I and listen I'm
a relatively smart guy like I'm slightly
above the belt what do you just it might
my horns falling on Oh your hearts cut
off
I keep seeing them doing this I just
thought you were doing something saying
listen the ms-13 are animals okay only
two I walk up there five if I don't like
their hearts all the time with the
father like the hordes President Trump I
don't know that was quarterblack cared
at a lot of those Crowder shows shut up
you dumbass I think they've had to leg
with the hordes so I preach no listen
there are sometimes really simple
answers and that's okay and that's why
we're going to be releasing to change my
mind book here hopefully before the end
of the year a booklet on campus there
shouldn't be too much because sometimes
there are simple answers not everything
lives in the realm of nuance know you're
told for a long time like well not
everything is black and white well
that's true but not everything requires
a soliloquy sometimes it's really simple
are there conservatives who are bad at
of course there are you see a lot of
them I had one person once tell me in
Canada that that Chinese people
shouldn't be allowed to get home loans
yeah I don't know I don't have anywhere
to go with that I was just like well see
yeah okay don't even get that and then a
really good person meant it anyway I
don't know what's your name sir what's
that what's that is that a hockey helmet
is that holy stink yet from World War
two polish think it's from World War two
my name is Alex Taylor coming thank you
for being here I have a quick question
all right how are babies made and what
is best way to raise babies
well let's be honest that first question
has been answered because if you're a
heterosexual female or homosexual male
here you now know how babies are made
what is the best way to raise babies
listen I don't have babies so I know and
I get people look what are you gonna
breed and like well first off I'm not a
horse secondly you know listen I still
got a dog Oh at home and he needs a lot
of care and when we have time what are
you saying ah I don't know what you're
saying I have no idea go back to
fondling your horns I'm very confused I
this is really easy though I had a great
dad
I've talked about this a lot and I know
a lot of people had become conservative
in they're in college now which is great
you see a lot of people not obviously
not just myself of people like Ben
Shapiro Jordan Peterson there are a lot
of people out there changing hearts and
minds right now where people are going
into college not conservative and coming
out conservative I will tell you this
I've been around since I think was 2006
on YouTube 2009 is one of drink
political videos okay we did these
political it would get like a few
thousand plays and that was a huge hit
back then right the Young Turks were
calling me out and talking about how
much I sucked right now they won't they
will utter any name not name steven
crowder when you show up to change
speech in austin as chanc that's kind of
what happens
[Applause]
but I will say this so for that's really
hardening for this that's just it warms
my cockles to see that because it tells
me that the people who are outnumbered
12 to 1 in staff the people who are
really afraid of the climate on college
campus you are changing hearts and minds
because when I started out this didn't
exist this wouldn't be possible for
conservatives on campus we actually
would have been able to book in an
advanced could have filled Hill
Auditorium with how many people are here
I don't think that there has been any
kind of a political show like that in
recent memory here there probably is
someone's gonna believe Noam Chomsky
will shut up okay for the purposes of
this story so that's great that being
said I did not become a conservative in
college I will tell him a conservative
pretty young why because my dad had
these conversations with the dinner
table and I think Ronald Reagan said all
great change starts at the dinner table
and I was just a kid I was doing this
this cartoon our Thoreau PBS and I play
this character called the brain thank
you thank you cheers the Canadian gets
booed I was produced in Canada so think
about it I'm so torn Wow it was so fast
uh and I would get checks and my dad
would say okay what do you think about
this going to taxes what do you think
about a 52% marginal tax rate what do
you think about health care right we had
already put several people in the ground
because of Canadian health care and all
of these conversations started with my
dad and I will say this my dad and my
mother my mom was french-canadian and so
she'd understand American Pollock's
politics in the same degree but she was
principled she was more conservative on
the social issues and the moral issues
and in Quebec there are only liberals
and liberal separatists but they always
had these conversations with me as a
young child to the point where when I
went into high school I was having these
conversations with with teachers long
before college so if you're going to
raise your kids anyway people say don't
talk about religion in politics well
guess what happens when you don't talk
about religion politics with your kids
you have kids like the gentleman who has
I think it was Evan who asked a question
who's afraid to speak out in college you
think you're in bowling your children if
you're telling them don't speak religion
in politics are gonna go into college
more
are those kids get them ready with
information little warriors don't send
clocks let's send them out with info
Thank You mr. polish
all right you sir yes I appreciate you
got a lot of those Crowder hats okay
all right there you go thank you but you
just bought it now oh very nice what's
your name sir
Matt Traverse City Michigan Oh Traverse
City very nice cherries and fat commie
[ __ ] come from there that's pretty
much yeah Homer Michael Moore boo what
did someone say he's not from there
what's the story here like alright okay
go ahead here what's your question sir
at least my my question well the state
of Texas is treating you well would you
ever move back to the greatest state in
the Union Michigan Oh
no that was that was a brian Stelter
question that was very leading it's like
mr. trump would you ever consider being
respectful and kissing pass on air no
you're disgusting Leslie I can't talk
with him there's no reasoning you know
what I would I would consider it when
Michigan ditches their state ATS here I
hate to say this this is one thing I've
talked about it go understand
Texas is it's a petri dish you know what
Michigan you've still if you could just
annex two traits in Flint give it to
Canada you know just like to just tell
them what's on the ballot they're just
voting for free pot and tap yeah just
sounds good it's a good deal you get to
get high-end ed um so you have the same
kind of situation with eastern and
western michigan you look at Grand
Rapids I did a video with Ben yeah first
off people over there are nice they
really are they're Ritchie's for
somebody my my ear pieces if Ellickson
was tugging on the back of my Colorado
Stephens done lsv again kids people that
are nice I had a guy we were doing this
undercover sting of the college
socialists and this guy was complaining
I guess she sucks and you're the
divorces Nathanael they just really
destroyed this shitty human that's okay
what do you do is like the panhandles I
mean they really have you look at Grand
Rapids you compare it to Detroit you
look at one that's expanded one that's
done incredibly well one this
diversified one that really was
supported by free enterprise
conservative families and households and
that's one thing to I think a lot of
people here from Michigan were kind of
surprised how anyone here surprised
initially how vicious the attacks on
Betsy DeVos were yeah I think almost
everyone who's not a piece of crap yeah
you're like Betsy DeVos isn't she the
worst and everyone in Michigan is like
ah she like supports kids hospitals and
she's actually made schools better we're
pretty sure she's a [ __ ] really okay
I don't think that's allowed um so you
have an Eastern Michigan right you have
entirely democratic rule Detroit listen
I'm sorry I know some of you hipsters
like to go to Detroit and drink coffee
that's not how they live it doesn't save
the city alright sorry
Detroit needs to get rid of the crony
pub that the political corruption in
Detroit knows no bounds
uh I have Detroit entirely democratic
rule since I think Jerome Cavanaugh 1961
and then you have the other side of the
state or you have a place like Texas
right a place like Texas where it could
not get or fast enough people got rivers
even can't get their head around this
Texas okay it's not really fair to
compare countries like a good example
people talk about health care being a
human right and they try to compare us
to Norway or Denmark
it is like shut up
we're not socialist it's a lot more fair
to compare states I think and comparing
California or Michigan but I think
California Texas are great examples so
California is hemorrhaging people the
taxes are awful their economy is
collapsing underneath them according to
Al Gore they shouldn't even existed I
think four years ago but we're banking
on that climate change at some point and
then you have Texas right no state tax
and a surplus for as long as I can
remember you figure it out
and then you have these Californians who
move to Texas right they move to Texas
because I think what is it there's
Toyota that left State Farm Liberty
Mutual 15,000 jobs in one municipality
I think it's Plano Frisco one minutes a
pound of Texas it's a suburb of Dallas
and they come in and they try to vote
into the crappy blue policies they left
it's if you want to talk about the
delusions of today's left's just look at
Californians today who are chasing their
dreams their jobs and a better life for
their family in Texas and then trying to
turn it into California good example
very comparable would be people in a
migrant caravan on their way over here
burning the American flag
I never doing here burning the American
flag but I'll take it
think about that for a second and we're
told that we're mean and maybe something
one like oh okay I'm going to come to
your place for dinner like all right
fine by the way I'm going to take a
piece in your cooking path okay what is
happening then Don lemons like you know
you should let them enter you're racist
you like why are you just looking like a
dead Johnny Mathis back from the dead
you have nothing interesting to say Don
Lemon so a long way around to say
probably no not moving back to Michigan
but I do love Michigan Michigan has
unbelievable natural beauty I love the
New Zealand ice here outside of you know
the people who live in Detroit a nice um
and I really do appreciate thank for
your questions sir
all right we're gonna go over here Oh
mustard okay you're just is there an
inside joke here was that just the only
costume you had my friends mustard and
ketchup okay I love how ketchup is way
happier
because everyone loves him and with you
they're not so sure Oh a monster really
Gerald all right but mustard has the
question I couldn't tell if you were
mustard or you were you were the Bette
Midler and hocus-pocus with a little hat
they're going on but an Asian version
well are you are you Latino you Asian
you came both Indian Indian well she's
got the feathers on her head so you know
I'm a dot not a feather you're going
through your whole own dot feather thing
right now in a PS so you shouldn't be
one to throw stones or whatever the hell
it is you have left in India but go
ahead
oh now you're offended he's laughing his
ass off
okay what's your name sure I'm Shane
Shane nice to meet you Shane what's your
question Shane
so as a Indian vegan conservative I'm
very independent minded person and I
just can't comprehend the race card
we're like oh the whole hierarchy of
white people brown people this staying
out of the thing I just don't get it how
do you propose that I were to combat
that as I go into college and I talk to
yeah well I wouldn't propose you combat
it as a vegan you might not have the
vigor
[Applause]
now series Loki's laughing season why
it's a fun time to be here it's just
some kind of a leftist conversation and
look like oh my god I cannot believe he
said that to the dot Indian and I can't
believe she's dressed like First Nations
but it's really like a red sky just I am
so if I'm offended on so many levels
I don't they have mustard in India oh my
god I'm being racist and you said uh
Indian not any Indian if you Mexican is
trying to pass himself off your question
is how do you help combat that yeah
listen I think you are I think you are
just being you that's it
I mean here's the truth we have Eric
Eric Nimr a good friend a drug member on
the show good friend of Owen Benjamin
for people who know him former black
former black military on believe sir
he's one of my favorite jokes from an
Eric member I think I know I'm
butchering it here he can tell it to the
overflow room is he served in the
military because he wanted white people
to thank him for his freedom he's not
even that conservative Nimr he's like my
all my family they're all liberals are
all former Democrats and they just got
so crazy now no one in my family is a
democratic but I'm not really a
conservative you don't even have to be
conservative just be you I mean you're
you're an Indian right where are you
from what part of India the drop was
that my family's from Gujarat that I'm
Boudreau okay you were born here all
right so you want to get past it but you
want to throw it down in the college
resume he's like Shawn kicking the
victim of a hate crime but then when he
needs to it's like I'm gonna check the
Caucasian box so your name date your
native Indian non-native American you
should that's Native American over there
but your friend ketchup is positively
translucent I mean his 23 in these shows
up just it just doesn't even show up
it's like if I put this in dark mode
invert colors
and isn't that fantastic you two are
like a buddy cop film that's how you
answer it just don't be afraid again you
sold those back to its really simple
listen the coward's way way out is
really easy keep your head down I used
to talk about this because I wasn't
Hollywood and I felt I get to do it for
a long time you keep your head down you
say the right things you don't piss off
all the wrong people and eventually
right there's that pot of gold at the
end of the rainbow it's never there it's
never there so just do it be who you are
where you are people see you and you say
yeah by the way I'm a conservative you
you watch leftists head explode on a
second I thought you said you were a dot
yeah and I support lower taxes oh so is
the dot like a mini Charles Manson
swastika no you're just a horrible
person that would be my answer be who
you are what you're doing is great have
fun be a happy warrior just don't be
intimidated if you will who tell you
what you have to be because then the
problem is to listen I make fun of
vegans mostly because they can't fight
back but it's okay it's okay for you to
be a vegan
just take it in stride and that's what I
love about you I appreciate you ask the
question just don't be afraid thank you
so much we're gonna move on whoa that is
a busy shirt is that writing or is that
just a pattern it's a Hawaiian shirt oh
okay all right you from Hawaii oh no I'm
a Hollywood's new favorite socialist
what's that you're what Hollywood oh
okay I see what you did there yes I like
it I like it
I got it okay I see it now you know I
didn't see it before the red pants the
hair yeah you get the hair mom okay Ace
Ventura all right I appreciate it was
just a last-minute costume I mean it
wasn't quite like the mug guy he's like
it's last minute so you got a tank top
and a shirt that kind of I don't know
Jim Carrey clothes all right okay what
your name sir Eli Eli all right Eli
we're going Old Testament what would you
like what's your question my question is
so I'm 18 so I don't have to identify
with Millennials thank God wait you're a
lucky yes I'm lucky so important [ __ ]
said Kevin Spacey from a cell continued
all right I really hope Alliance sure
could give me an Aloha
stop stop stop clapping I'm terrible all
right go ahead but no so do you have any
hope for Gen Z you know being more
conservative they've kind of talked
about oh absolutely
so what do you what do you see that's
doing or what do we have to do to
finally get the country going so your
generation Z at 18 where does
interagency start exactly in 1990
something you can identify I could tell
it's like 96 yeah no I know you gotta
fire as a baby yeah I collect Social
Security like what I'm like I know I
could pick it later and technically get
more but I just want to steal stuff now
they're like okay no listen this is true
and I appreciate you I thank you for the
question Eli this is actually a really
important question
ah Generation Z is possibly the most
conservative generation ever now I know
yeah I mean you know that's why they
were so busy trying to push David hog
out that's a great example generation Z
is probably more pro-gun than it don't
boo me I say is it's not like Voldemort
okay I like saving them in a boo you
have less leeway because you're Canadian
so Generation Z is probably more pro-gun
than any generation prior why they talk
about gun culture 2.0 because you've
played these video games where you see
these ultra realistic guns you want to
try them out shoot them or not even
necessarily pro-second amendment and
then all of a sudden that kind of folds
into that also tend to be very Pro free
speech and here's something that I've
noticed and I actually think as is um I
haven't heard a lot of people talk about
this is entirely a theory it's
conjecture okay so wait oh please tell
me you're dressed as a terrorist I
couldn't see you until just now
delicious food by the way I think there
was a place actually what was the place
that actually was funneling money to
Hezbollah it's the sheesh right or
possibly all of them but let's go with
Lachish that was Ashish yes I remember
and listen you know they hate the Jews
but by God their tabbouleh is tasty so
generation Z there are winning issues
pro-gun Pro free speech they've rejected
this sort of pseudo third wave feminism
there's a lot of progress being able
generations even this is just kind of a
theory that I have you know Millennials
were sort of the last generation to
bridge that gap with social media right
Millennials when you eat when were weak
and I guess technically millennial at 31
I'm not entirely sure
one person's like a cheer and then
everyone's booing because I'm still
Canadian I get it I'm gonna leave very
soon people are terrible I'm never
coming back to Ann Arbor no I'm coming
back
and then we're gonna go up to Torch Lake
and take a dump of Michael Moore's dock
symbolically get to see that now
otherwise we were like Michael Moore
receives an envelope he's pretty sure
it's the guy who said he's gonna take a
dump on its dock so we were the last
generation when I grew up we didn't we
didn't have face but we'd have Twitter
damn snapchat the closest thing was
later on we had MySpace and that sort of
became like the whorehouse of the
internet before that there was
Friendster before that there was Sangha
which was it was just nothing but it was
nothing but Asians and and you know God
Indians runs anga well you don't really
have it right so that's the last
generation where remember you didn't
really get the red pen scores had to be
evened out because you could insulate
those kids we had kids who were bullied
a little bit too much when you go to
baby boomers and Generation actually we
had sort of we just tossed them all on a
school together right we created the
federal Department of Education let's
say let's see what happens here okay
it's not really working out that well
people are getting their asses kicked
test scores aren't really going up but
then generation Z they've been raised
now with social media their entire life
which is terrible in a way because the
worst things you can possibly read right
you see on social media it's toxic it's
just like a drug you really need to keep
usage of it absolutely limited not today
Twitter Instagram Facebook
crowd are you of em takeover shameless
plug but you can't really hide and so I
don't think professors I don't think
parents are able to insulate Generation
Z so much so you have this generation
right Millennials who kind of made it to
college had been told that they're
amazing and they're perfect every way
that they were and none of us are and
they went there and there was a reality
check in the workplace when she know
kinds of problems of Millennials in the
workplace where's generations II have
been told the most horrendous thing that
could possibly imagine
since they could use a smartphone and so
I think that'll have negative
ramifications but again they have the
ability to fat check any both crap same
thing anything I've said here tonight
he's full of crap they're half the time
and that's what generation Z and they're
very pro-gun Pro free speech so I
actually have a lot of hope for
Generation Z I see far more people who
are willing to listen and engage in a
conversation because once you cut
through the white noise of all the
terrible crap being said on social media
you know we have generated the younger
people are always the ones who come up
and change my mind
and actually want to talk about it it's
the oh it's the Millennials doing that
gap so I really do think the tides of it
the pendulum swings the other way and
generations II statistically as well
something else that's undeniable they
are more conservative right now at this
point in their lives then baby boomers
were so right now let me go well they're
really not that conservator liberal yeah
they're liberal but that's expected when
you're young but for the first time we
actually have sometimes on certain
issues a plurality of generations II
folks what do you call them generations
ears
zere's the trans community one again
[Music]
till now damn it Caitlyn Jenner I'm not
going to x-men cover go of it they are
more conservative on certain issues than
any generation before them at that
snapshot in time in their lives and
that's one we don't hear about it's
something to look out for it's some
really good news and it's also oh I want
fewer and fewer people to be afraid
because Generation Z is not as cowardly
as many Millennials were and that really
warms my heart thank you so much Eli for
your question I appreciate it all right
socialism is for food sir you got a
wonderful beard what's your name
Seth barber from Grand Rapids I didn't
you say so Paulo from Grand Rapids
what's your not Seth barber barber all
you give me a last name all right we're
very formal okay well we're quiet
I know I was on the mind because I just
talking with Owen Benjamin backstage
without snake Islands I didn't remember
the snake that's a great yes just bomb
it I just it's off the coast of South
paw it's like eight squared me every
single meter square meter there's like
eight snakes there flying snakes there's
snakes to hunting packs these snakes
only exist on system do you mean the
ecosystem of only snake island nuke it
for crying out loud
okay yes go ahead mister South Paulo
well this question was straight from my
wife um and his personal one so you
don't have to answer if you don't want
right well that's a little weird you
asking your wife's personal question so
do me a favor
ask it as a woman that was my Christian
tell if ever like Maddie
I don't know why I yeah of course at
some point but is that it the only
question from your wife well that was
the only question that she wanted to
know yeah I know well listen I mean it's
a loaded gun I gotta be careful with
this thing right I got a lively
especially after this you know my wife
is visiting Michigan - she got family on
a walk back and he's asked let's chaps
and Ranger panties in a right away out
of that whoa whoa whoa let's take it
back a notch yeah I know it's a personal
question I can't necessarily answer all
the personal questions but I'll tell you
this I don't like kids
I know I like okay I know I like my kids
like my I was like man I'm really scared
I was photos I don't want kids and like
kids are just really annoying sticky and
so and he's like I didn't like kids at
all and then I had like you oh my god
okay all right so no I like some kids
actually Johnny boy who's a producer
mind his daughter is just adorable
yes um yeah but she's very very
aggressive for a young girl she's three
and she asked me to marry her and I were
like oh that's cute that's like that's
pretty cute okay we don't need to do
that right she's like now and then she
walks up she grabs me behind the next
yearís Steven Steven look at me look at
me okay she goes you're what I've always
dreamed of it's cute I'm like first off
we mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger love second to make situations
even more awkward right I turn to my
friend Johnny boy producer wonderful man
and I turn to Minnie she what I've
always dreamed of and I go hey Johnny
just so you know we're Bros I would
never take advantage
after he peed himself laughing you had
me hauled out in cuffs so yeah
officially but tell your wife say and
thank you for the bringing them ugh yeah
can I just send another message real
quick yeah hey honey I love you and for
the phone number that you put on my mug
thank you the first three digits is mine
but the last four are yours all right
okay so she has pregnant brain okay
what's your name Elizabeth Elizabeth
thank you what time is it today probably
two more questions
few more we're probably about okay we
have two more questions all right one
more though you just said - OH
- all right it's like an Auburn Auburn
Hey - that was - I don't yell you stop
yelling all right who thinks they have a
really really good question the guy up
front didn't even raise his hand he's
like I don't I don't this kind of heat
I'm all right we're gonna go two more
okay since you were easier what's your
name sir Trevor Trevor
nice to meet you Trevor okay what is
your question Trevor by the way what's
your name sweetheart with that with a
full feather head Indian native outfit
here what's Elizabeth
oh it says Elizabeth Warren on your
shirts okay so that's your costume but
what's your real name is he okay
so you just decided you wanted to walk
through this campus right now and piss
everybody off on your way to the show
tonight good for you
pintu him too
let's all be a little bit more like easy
and that guy but I'm pretty sure she's
cute he's just a racist so don't be like
that guy he's doing sending clocks with
get er done stickers that look
remarkably like Isis flags I don't know
stop asking questions alright so you've
mentioned that the movie the edge
starring Anthony Hopkins yes have not
seen at the edge with Anthony Hopkins
Alec Baldwin it is the single most
conservative film ever made and by the
way the guy who created it David Mamet
Glengarry Glen Ross is where the most
prolific playwrights ever he wrote in
New York New York Times or Washington
Post an article why I'm no longer a
brain-dead liberal he wrote the edge
before he wrote that article that's pic
it's proof positive of someone who's a
conservative and doesn't know it yet if
you have not seen the edge please go
rent it it's unbelievable
it is the perfect motion picture except
for one scene where the green screen is
kind of obvious with this grizzly bear
and you're like it would have been
perfect so it's like a 9.9 but yes the
edge sorry I guess if we talk about
snake eye over the edge I'm gonna get
jacked understandable so in the movie
Anthony Hopkins plays a rich powerful
man and Charles yes and you know he's
very helpful to the people in the movie
and yeah I was wondering why you think
in the real world people on the Left
would vilify someone like that with
money power even though he's helping
people right you mean not named Soros
okay no I think it's a great and that's
why the edge for people don't let me
give a little bit of kind of a briefer
the edge is a debriefing on it the edge
is really Anthony Hopkins this
billionaire guy and he actually so
spoiler alert he starts off as a really
good guy and you're waiting for every
single film right the billionaire is
gonna
kid the very few films where the
billionaire actually is a good guy who
saves bad people who saves some people
who are selfish and here's one thing as
this is a big defining difference
between the right and the left okay we
talked about this where they identity
politics we think it applies only to you
know race mustard and ketchup but it
applies to classes to listen money
amplifies character if you're a terrible
person you're gonna be a terrible person
with money if you're a good person
you're gonna be a good person with money
and the truth is typically speaking we
like to beat a lot of you'll teach us
that everyone has to cheat and game the
system and lie and screw people to
become wealthy no to get into DC yeah
most of the time but not to run a
business most business owners in this
country they're paying people the first
people think about when they're headed
to the pillow at night their employees
when they wake up when they go to bed
it's the last it's the last blue thing
about when they go to bed it's the first
bility thing about when they get up in
the edge this film it really is an
unbelievable film because again like I
said David Mamet didn't know that he was
a conservative and he wrote this whole
film and you're waiting for the guy the
billionaire to be the bad guy and he
never shows up the good thing is when we
talk about being open-minded and it's
funny right they talk about the gender
binary there's no gender binary we don't
not we want to go with science but when
it comes to success when it comes to
finances when it comes to power there's
good successful powerful strong and evil
the poor the downtrodden therefore the
good have to give all their crap but the
truth is sometimes the the powerful they
got that way by actually doing the right
thing and sometimes someone who's been
on food stamps for their entire life not
everyone some people get a tough break
sometimes sometimes the guy who's been
suckling at the government teat ever
since he was a small child it's actually
just a selfish lazy person not always
and sometimes the guy who makes a ton of
money
lenka Soros is not a good person we
don't have to fit into this it's just so
funny that the left tries to act is that
they're open-minded and we're gonna
we're gonna break out of the gender
binary I am born right and you say yeah
what what about like what about like
this idea that wealthy people have to be
bad and poor people are altruistic true
and I don't buy it and I think that's
why it's important I think the left
vilifies success again de left
automatically grants you the moral high
ground I've talked about this before and
it's a very dangerous mode of thinking
and here's the thing this is why so many
young people are liberals left this and
they become more conservatives they get
older so you do ask what do you do I do
think that's why I say smiling being
apathetic being nice having a good time
that changes people what starts people's
change what starts them on that
trajectory is not always you know the
fact it's not always just giving them a
Thomas ol book it's not talking about
marginal tax rates it's not talking
about a GDP that the left said could
never possibly happen under Trump like
high [ __ ] it's not that sometimes it's
how they feel around you and you have to
be the life of the party you have to be
a good person because the left grants
the moral high ground to people who are
the poorest and most downtrodden and
automatically assumes they're correct
it's ending with Israel and Palestine
look at that and that's unbelievable I
know we're gonna have some libertarians
here who's false flag all right listen
but or a little YouTube people the Jews
we're back there again but if you look
at Israel and Palestine you look at some
people who tunnel underneath towns to
target women and children and then they
defend themselves by hiding in grade
schools and mosques again around women
and children and Israel builds up an
entire basically a force field to defend
who now who now who now they're women
and children the left hates Israel
look at the charitable it's on
statistical eon deniable to wealthy
people this country particularly
conservative christians they tend to
give the most of charity it's not even
close there's a book I think it was by
David Brooks who really cares is I think
the book at her talks about this the
single biggest determining factor is
their faith and then their political
affiliation and then particularly level
of income middle income people don't
give as much as upper middle income
people and not as much as wealthy people
and poor people give less than wealthy
people and I know you're saying well
that's just because they poured on as
much to give as a percentage of their
income that doesn't mean that all poor
people are bad it just means that we
shouldn't grant them automatically the
moral high ground and that's why you see
the left today it's a prime example the
edge is such a shock are you watching
like oh my god I thought billionaires
were always bad why because the left is
trying to sell you that the guy in the
ant if a guy dragging an old man from a
car and punching him in his face who's
on the way to work to build the crap
that guy punching you in the face
probably wants to be stolen from him at
gunpoint by the federal government they
want you to side with that guy why
because he's wearing a ripped up hoodie
so he must have the moral high ground
don't buy it it's easy to fall into this
trap because most people most people are
empathetic they're sympathetic they look
at people who need a leg up and you say
oh my gosh you know what this guy needs
I feel for this guy and you want to help
them and the left tells you well that's
because they were screwed by somebody
just like you or someone who's wealthy
it's not true there are good people who
are wealthy and powerful and there are
bad people who are poor and weak there
are good people who are strong and there
are Betty that's actually one thing I
actually just misspoke there are no bad
people who are strong the only one that
you can look at we're talking about
strength of character there are people
who are weak of character and people who
are good people who are strong you feel
a backbone people have spine and guess
what those people can be rich poor black
white yellow Indian orange in it doesn't
matter they span the spectrum but the
left want you to think it exists in a
binary hey there's that word again it
doesn't so I think that's why that film
was probably one of my favorites is
shocking to watch go watch the edge and
read more David Mamet alright last
question I know a few people said they
have really really we gotta get real
get a good one one second here I think
you're looking to just make mixin
alright okay let's see let's see I'm pro
life changer when I already had shirt
then we have to get going
alright what's your name sir my name my
name is Matt what Oh but because you
dressed like a terrorist I have to
answer you it's what this oh he
disagrees all right well sorry you
should have gotten up sooner I disagree
with your 40-yard dash alright uh yeah
let's go my name is madness recorder I
wanted to first off I wanted to thank
you I wouldn't have ever watched the
Gosnell movie if I uh if you hadn't you
know promoted it on your show that was a
great movie so fantastic film I took one
of my liberal friends and she enjoyed it
as well but my question is two parts
first off in discussing things with my
family what would you say to the people
who accuse you of being an AIDS denier I
understand that you're you know that
it's joking when you when you go out and
say that obviously no it is a real thing
right absolutely just on that group sex
with strata so there's truck stop and
strangers but would you agree that have
no use dirty hyper deviate needles we're
good but would you agree that
heterosexual people can get AIDS as well
sure sure yeah it's a statistical non
risk but yeah go ahead what's part two
part two is uh how would you help me
shut down all the people who keep asking
what happened to Savannah computer well
it's some commuters back in Germany so
you send an important question so I get
back in Germany right now we wish them
the best you know that's always kind of
complicated as far as an AIDS denier I
don't know when that start you know we
talked about oh I don't remember this
Oprah said one in [ __ ] one in five
couples will have AIDS by the year 1994
I think was 1994 1996 that includes
heterosexual couples it's never even
been close I've never denied that aids
exists again this is what the left does
they take something that's true and you
say the AIDS epidemic was a host what
was the hoax I don't know but you
remember when I was in school and they
came and they said listen kids we need
to talk about a alright Gellin looks
like don't have unprotected sex like the
people in rent in the East Village or
use a bunch of dirty heroin needles and
we should be safe right like no no no
just if you have a friend who's like a
stripe on their knee don't touch them
and that's how they taught us to avoid
aids there was this false epidemic
rust upon the American public that
everyone was at risk and it just wasn't
true if anyone wants to call that a
denier all right then I guess I'm an
AIDS denier I guess I mean it's one of
those things that I don't really care
about that much but it's really
bastardized you see that by the left
we're going to go with one more question
I think you said you disagree is that it
you disagree okay let's go and I will
keep it one last question thank you sir
all right all right I wanted to know I
had a different question it was about
trans people I thought that it's not
necessary great to make fun of them
because it's kind of like punching down
but I wanted to know why you call this a
terrorist costume because it's funny
okay that's a comedy show they say the
whole rape and Hezbollah funding I think
of a bad perception in dearborn I know
you had a video there but I like that
extended invite to come and see how
Muslims were you live in Dearborn we
don't a lot are rate people or I'm glad
you don't and by the way I never said
everyone funded Hezbollah just Lachish
right yeah well that's just one guy me
there's 200,000 of us living in the
vicinity of he's just one guy sure I
mean the American government gives money
to Saudi Arabia and they're bombing the
hell out of Yemen right what is my great
what's the difference I mean you can't
just create this equivalency and say
that we're doing one thing what what
equivalents internet create well I'm you
just saying okay there's so one guy from
our town funded Hezbollah that doesn't
mean that every time we bring up
Dearborn oh it's a Muslim ghetto or
their funding Hezbollah yes so why do
you why do you portray us fairly why do
you have to call us a terrorist costume
and all their funding Hezbollah don't
you see okay so first off first point I
think I've answered the question okay
it's funny
second second part about the hood [ __ ]
punching about funding Hezbollah I
talked about a specific restaurant that
was caught funding Hezbollah is this is
this a correct story or not
yeah it is a quick [ __ ] hijackers came
through Dearborn Michigan excuse me how
many hijackers came through Dearborn
Michigan I have no idea
take a wild guess and you mean the 9/11
hijackers yeah 9/11 let's go with that
for sorry I mean maybe they're right now
of course not everyone and you're just
like not everyone in Dearborn supports
your view of course not everyone in
Dearborn is a terrorist right and I
don't think that you're dressed like a
terrorist to be clear just like I was
talking about Owen Benjamin he's dressed
like Liberace he's not a gay pianist
right all right this partners is meant
to be a comedy show now of course how it
relates to is law
versus Christianity like that question
okay I think there is a shocking
statistic a shocking number of people
who support things that aren't in line
with Western values and that's okay
people I mean can you name me a single
Islamic country where there's freedom of
speech let me have any other states one
well that's kind of a Western value
though right you can't expect us to have
[Applause]
speech though I do I can't tell someone
in my home country to support or not
support it because they have their own
way oh you can't tell them what to do I
can say they're wrong you appreciate
that people have different ways of
living sure I can this is a big thing
too by the way I think was your name sir
Muhammad Ali Muhammad Ali is actually
your Muhammad Ali that really thank you
for question Muhammad Ali appreciate us
hear from Hamid oh thank you
this is crazy to me when people say like
why can't you appreciate different world
views I can I appreciate different world
views that's why I listen the guy was
bold enough to answer to ask a question
I appreciate let's not shut him down
okay let's not do the mob rule here all
right I appreciate different points of
view I explore different points of view
that's why I'm free to say I don't like
the crappy ones and I'm sorry but if
your country doesn't believe in freedom
of speech and you said it not me it's a
Western value guess what I'm going with
the Western values country there's a
country that's okay that's enough your
questions done if there's a country that
says all right a woman needs X amount of
witnesses to prove a rape and right here
we're putting Cavan on trial because
Christi Ford said something might have
happened some time some space of I have
no idea with where when how who and the
people who she said who said I wasn't
there I was completely full of crap
if we're gonna [ __ ] about that but then
talk about countries where people get
off with rape completely scot-free I go
I'm with the Western values country if
we have countries
there are countries where there's death
for apostasy I don't care whether it's
Islam whether it's Christianity or their
burning churches and record numbers and
there are people saying hey you know
what I think that's wrong
I'm with the Western values country if
there's a cop if there's a place out
there where people say that you should
actually be killed for converting and
you should be subjected to some kind of
dhimmi to tour a poll-tax
if you don't fall in line with some kind
of religion or if there are entire
administration systems of government
that rely on subjugation conversion or
death I'm with the country that doesn't
do that and here's the thing it doesn't
mean I hate those people it doesn't mean
I hate all of the people in those
countries but guess what if it comes
into some kind of a global conflict or
the country that says yes free speech
yes women's rights yes freedom of
religion yes a democratic republic in
the countries that say none of that all
right
Surf's Up we're dropping some bombs that
I'm talking about right now aren't worth
fighting for it doesn't mean that I hate
people it just means I think they're
wrong and that's one thing that left
constantly tells us well you have to
think someone's right to appreciate it
what's that I'm not a big fan of Saudi
Arabia it's a pretty generalized
question to show we are starting Arabia
your move Canadian
and I want to go to this you're good
you're done thank you free to a speech
let's we'll kind of understand a little
better we can talk about to show them
you get to keep asking questions
other people have lined up I appreciate
the questions we do have to get going
one thing I wanted to go back to was
where we talked about earlier this idea
of fear of whether you should speak out
in your class with your professors well
here's something that's pretty pretty
remarkable that person said they were
afraid I understand it we just had
someone say yeah but those are Western
values freedom of speech how can you say
that they're right one person is afraid
of saying Western values are right I
support freedom of speech and one
person's not afraid to say how do you
know that those values are right both
live in this country why do we make
trans jokes why do we make jokes about
Islam why do we tell jokes that
sometimes around the edge where
sometimes we write it we look in the
pitch meeting and oh and nimr and I go
man this really shouldn't make air and
we say but we kind of have to do it it's
because when people tell you what you
can't talk about what you can't make fun
of you know that you have to do it
because somebody has to do it and here's
something else I want to talk to you
about you know Jordan Peterson talks
about telling the truth about or at
least not lying and I've talked about
this a lot too telling the truth
particularly not lying to yourself why
because the lies you tell yourself will
eat away at your soul for the rest of
your life you cannot look yourself in
the mirror lie to yourself and have
respect for yourself as a human being
and you can't you can't even hope to
change hearts or minds but there's
something else that's really important
with truth and to the man I think it was
a Evan who asked with his cape and it's
happened recently I was actually
visiting northern Michigan on a long
weekend and there's a lady a friend of
our family her husband died and we said
listen how are you doing and you know
what she said you know what it's been
really hard it's been really hard the
furnace went out and I just kind of feel
like I can't handle one more thing
and we said listen know what you I know
you feel that way I can't imagine what
you're going through
I can only try to imagine but you
probably can you probably can't handle
one more thing and she said wow thanks
that was just that's what I needed to
hear it sounds silly there was someone
else who had just recently gotten
married
we love this person she's a server and
she's always very she's always very nice
very friendly we said hey how's it going
we just got married
and she said you know what honestly it's
kind of kind of been tough it's been a
tough first year you know what I said my
wife and I said the first year of
marriage is always the toughest and I've
written about that I've written about
abstinence until marriage I know they're
like what you just did the training name
a joke yeah I was effing until I was
married so still kind of a
traditionalist Christian here and we're
always taught this idea that there's
this honeymoon phase where marriage is
easy the first year know again if you
understand that you're flawed too very
flawed imperfect people joining in unity
the first year is hard and I said this
to this woman and so do my wife is gay
listen it gets easier see a counselor it
helps your two people who live very
different lives and now you're joining
them of course you for you in a certain
way you do the dishes let alone how you
make your bed let alone how you view the
world people are going to see it
differently marriages hard the first
year and she said you know what you're
the first people who said that now we
didn't say let us teach you about
marriage I didn't to the Steven Seagal
thing I've been married four times
and all my wives say you're amazing you
know it's not like like Steven Seagal
didn't you poop your pants once--once
that's a lie
we just said marriage is really hard we
fought like cats and dogs the first year
and it helped her what you said listen I
know it listen I I know it's really hard
it's really hard marriage is hard it's
hard when you lose a spouse sometimes
just speaking the truth it's not about
how it helps yourself it's about
everyone around you that's the huge
thing when we talk about right or wrong
left or right black or white Indian or
[ __ ] right there's one thing there's
one through line and I hope you get this
in the show and obviously we do sad tire
and sometimes they go a little bit too
far there's one through line that
matters above all else and it's truth it
is truth and it's not only because truth
we've turned about the truth will set
you free so often people hear this we
talk about truth and they talk about
speaking truth to power they're talking
about themselves or talking about why I
need to be truthful because that's
better for me in the long run because no
one's that good of a liar right we hear
that all the time you better tell the
truth because no one's that good of a
liar but how often do we hear people
talk about how you telling the truth and
not your truth but living the truth and
telling the truth helps everybody around
you and if you want to if you want to
know why that is
you doubt that for a second and you talk
about how you're afraid to speak out in
class each other how you're maybe afraid
to speak out in the entertainment
industry well guess what there are a lot
of other people out there like you who
aren't necessarily telling the truth
because they're afraid and wouldn't it
be great if every time you walked into a
room whether it's a classroom whether
it's a business meeting you were
actually aware of the fact that that
sampling represented the general
populace and it was like the roar that
you hear here because the truth of them
just set you free it helps every single
person around you and right now today in
2018 it is not something that I
recommend it is absolutely your civic
duty to speak the truth as often
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]